my guys huh hey yeah what the hell are
you doing to me what am i doing I'm
coming to step that's what I'm doing
what are you doing no no you got the
wrong step you run I promise you Joey he
got a bunch of Greek letters on her it's
just right that's how fresh this is ah
whoo brothers I will only know what we
know and go where we please big brother
Oh keV okay and big brother we all found
it day before yesterday day before
yesterday for your sake I was owned by
the Chinese dude he had a little Chinese
store 13:53 license the name who from
Chinese guy ah he got a cane you got a
cane now look at all hey that's not the
right cane this is for an old person I
don't know who it's for I need this
stability okay look just over there the
what look to you right unless they step
in I don't want none day stepping were
they gonna step it this is like a
banquet they step in classic no that's a
bunch of odd to know who's celebrating
somebody birthday yesterday this happy
birthday decades they've been doing this
for decades well for decades it look
like they didn't got it wrong I'm
willing to bet the idiot with the orange
boots got it wrong and it's only one
person so you called it my chapter wrong
if this must be the wrong address I'm
gonna go outside and see if it's next
door you better put a coat on it's cold
I brother you don't get cold when you
step hey tell whoever I'm in here
birthday I said head birthday